a lot of people are obviously super
excited about
the last episode of this series dropping
tonight and i know that people will
celebrate in their own way uh is there a
way that you're celebrating are you
doing a special sort of screening or is
it just like yeah we're we're having a
big screening uh tomorrow um where
they're gonna uh play all six episodes
and um i'm gonna be there for that and
then afterwards we'll see
the experience of getting back into this
whole thing after having taken a break
for so long uh you know the last time we
talked you were talking to me about what
it felt like being on the set
but i've been watching you do your tour
for you know talking to all of us
talking to the press how has that
experience been for you getting back
into all that
it's been really great you know um
i don't know there's just been a lot of
sort of enthusiasm for this project and
um and just nice to get to go around and
and talk about another star wars project
that i'm a part of
it's been really cool a lot of actors
talk about how they feel watching
themselves on screen and i don't know
how you have been traditionally with
watching yourself in your projects but
does it make things easier when it's not
your face on screen the entire time
definitely
definitely um yeah i know i'm the same i
i'm usually not too too big on watching
myself but uh but this is different and
and
um and certainly that last episode
episode five uh with the with the
flashback um that was that was good fun
to get to watch that i was like
traveling back in time
um the vader that we're getting in this
i think a lot of people are heralding
this as
uh
one of the best versions of vader we've
ever gotten and for me personally it's
that mix of like
mystery and menace but also because of
the nature of the show
it's um
you know watching vader even if you even
though you don't see vader's face
watching him cope with the ghosts of his
own past what was your approach to
making sure that this vader would be
memorable and for a lot of people maybe
the ultimate version of vader
[Music]
you know i think it all starts with the
writing um and the scripts um
and they they really did an excellent
job in in in crafting uh uh the darth
vader character into the story um and
then of course debra our director
um she deserves so much of the credit i
mean you know it really is all her
vision and um and i just get to show up
and and and play with her it's good fun
uh going into the final episode a lot of
people have had theories about you know
what's going to happen
what character is going to survive what
characters aren't going to survive we
know for sure which ones will make it
through right if you've ever seen
anything else that's star wars but do
you pay attention at all to to the ideas
that people have about all these
characters that they've grown uh
attached to
um i mean i i hear about a lot of these
like you know uh different theories
um and there's there's lots of fun stuff
that i had sort of no concept of
um
but yeah i mean i think that's sort of
the fun of it is is sort of fans getting
to sort of uh
theorize about
different sort of character arcs and
where that could go and
um yeah
um
we talked a little bit about the idea of
spinning off
into
another series or maybe even another
film series where vader is
you know the central character
have you had any talks about that
recently
uh we haven't had any any any
conversations about that yet
so nothing that i can really speak to
there but of course on my end i would
you know i would be thrilled to get to
continue with it yeah yeah um
how much of
uh
the star wars fandom has have you
actually had a chance to
get in touch with like are people
reaching out to you somehow are you are
you able to get from them
the feeling of what their anticipation
has been for this and how
you know maybe satisfied they've been so
far with what they've seen
um
really just sort of in my sort of uh
direct interactions with people you know
i don't i don't have social media so i
can't really keep up with that stuff um
but just meeting people and and sort of
hearing their their impression of the
show
um has been really rewarding yeah yeah
would you be satisfied with like
i had the opportunity to meet mark
hamill a couple years ago and i didn't
even realize how amazing it would be
just just him being there hanging out
and how open he's been with his fans and
he went through this whole thing of like
you know back in the day um
figuring out where he fits in this whole
entertainment thing and what it means
that he is luke
what do you think it means for you that
you've been anakin and that you're vader
now as well because moving into the
future like we said there's
opportunities but it might not even be
something you want to do every year it
might be something that happens every 10
every 20 like how do you feel about your
place and all this right now
um well if i if i had that opportunity i
would i would you know
be very grateful for that um
you know
my place in star wars um i got to i got
to play you know an incredible character
and
um and and now getting to sort of come
back and and explore darth vader a
little bit more
uh it's just been a very rich experience
um
but yeah you know just just very sort of
grateful and thankful for all of it
as we're
we've been peeling back the layers of
the story episode by episode and seeing
all these very cool reveals and things
that fans have been anticipated seeing
and
being surprised by a lot of other things
is there anything coming up in the
finale
that you know spoiler free obviously
uh that you can say is
really exciting for the fans um i i
spoiler free is difficult that's a
difficult territory um but yeah i'm very
excited for this last episode uh there's
some there's some very uh powerful stuff
in it um i
i don't know what i can tell you but but
will they hug will they go you know what
salt water under the bridge don't count
on it
you